okay the starting position is really
complicated what do we do with white and
what do we do with black and our opening
moves when I was starting it seemed to
me like all my chess pieces were calling
on me and telling me move me move me get
me into the game and you know like that
was really hard because they were all
crying but they wanted to participate
and it wasn't easy to formulate a plan
well one of the things is when we look
at the starting position we try to find
targets or weaknesses in our opponent's
camp
oftentimes we can't do it on move 1 we
have to wait for the game to develop but
if we look at the starting position for
a moment we see that this pawn on a 7 is
protected only once correct by the rook
protects the spot this pawn on B 7 is
protected only once by the bishop this
pawn on c7 is protected only once by the
Queen so it might seem to us that we
should target these pawns if we continue
down the board this pawn on D 7 is
protected four times four times how is
this pawn protected four times once by
the King once by the Queen once by this
bishop and once by this knight so
wouldn't make a lot of sense for us to
develop our forces and try to attack
this pawn on d7 right because that's our
opponent strong point yes young men
yes that too how many times is that
protected also for let's continue our
journey let's just be sure that we
understand that the King protects the
pawn the Queen protects the pond the
bishop protects upon and finally the
night we continue our journey how many
times is that pond protected charlie
correct and this pawn on g7 also once
and also by the bishop this pawn on h7
is protected one time by the room okay
it's it starts with this just this
knowledge we start thinking that we
shouldn't target this guy or this guy
but maybe this guy this guy this guy or
this guy this guy this guy because those
guys are only protected once one of the
favorite places to target is this pawn
on f7 because it's protected by the king
if we win this pawn on a 7 we win a pump
maybe it's not such a great deal but if
we win this pawn on f7 we make the King
on e8 vulnerable today we're going to
look at a game between grandmasters raw
gulab draw gulab Vela Maravich he was
from Yugoslavia Serbia today and his
opponent is American Lube America valid
glue bomber Luba shy column he was my
coach by the way one of my many coaches
but Lew Bosh is originally from
Czechoslovakia or what is today called
the Czech Republic
he lives in Reston Virginia which is a
suburb of Washington DC okay
and he played just a brilliant game well
actually he was victimized in a
brilliant game and let's see what his
opponent dragula 'b bella Maravich did
with white open e for d6 d4 Knight f6
Knight c3 now here the most popular move
for black is to play g7 g6 and Bishop g7
fianchetto the bishop on the King site
that transposes into a variation called
the perc defense the perc defense Lu
Bosch played another move very very
challenging black brings his pawn into
the center and invites a trade of Queens
Cavalli
knew that his opponent well america CH
was a great attacking player and Vela
Maravich has won many many many
brilliant games so that was why Koval ik
invited the trade of Queens Bela
Maravich declined to trade Queens and
instead developed his knight notice that
when he brought his knight to f3 he's
putting pressure against this pawn on e5
black defended against the pressure with
97 the knight came from b8 to d7
protecting the pawn on e5 Bishop c4 ah
Bishop c4 remember what I was saying
about this pawn on f7 white starts to
target this pawn on f7 with his bishop
and maybe maybe he can Menace Knight g5
to attack that pump
bishop Issa yeah Bishop e7 invites white
to capture this pawn right away what do
you think should white capture this pawn
right away
look why yes the King will kill the
bishop that is no question about it the
King will kill the bishop but but the
King is still vulnerable
we could play Knight g5 check attacking
the king yes but where can the King move
back if the King moves back to this
square e8 then the Queen is smothered
black's queen is trapped after night II
6 you see blacks queen is trapped
because that pawn on f7 is missing
the knight is going to win blacks Queen
if we go back how about if we move our
King here did anything change no you
still Charlie and you still win blacks
Queen correct but what about King g8
that is the best move correct that is
okay young man or the king can hold to
g6 into the Queen the White Queen ever
that's true but in this position what
would White play young man still 96 okay
correct still night II 6 attacking the
Queen but now in this case blacks Queen
can move Queen ecigs Charlie very good
night takes e7 isn't this kind of cool
the night correct attacks the Queen and
at the same time this night attacks this
rook so it's what we call a fork and
White has two pawns for his Bishop
correct he captured upon on f7 and now
he's captured upon on C set and this
position comes from what is called the
Philidor defense Philidor Denikin
Philidor was a 17th century French
playwright
isn't that cool and he wrote about this
position how many like White's position
with that fork isn't that cool
White's position is really good Philidor
let's match wits with Philidor a man
from the 17th century he's 300 years old
he said this position was good for black
ah how can that be
young man
no that's a nice way of getting is good
I like that
very insightful no it was this position
and Philidor said that black is the one
with the advantage thanks to this move
queen g6 whoa can't you just take the
rook how many just like to take the rub
that's a whole rook raise your hands if
you're ready to take the rook so he
takes so white takes the rook and
White's really happy right I mean he's
looking he's looking at that rook that's
off the board and he's looking at the
two pawns Black's missing two pawns in a
row that's off the board and all white
is missing as a bishop so you guys who
are thinking it's very good for white
but now Charlie you've got an idea
yes oh this is the devastating
counter-attack Queen takes g2 now notice
that if you let him Black is happy to
take your rook this was the point that
Daniken Philidor wrote about 300 years
ago young man yes what's your right
King 2e - there's an idea how about that
let's move King to e - so just a moment
so what that young gentleman is saying
is that when we move our King to e2
we're very clever we've protected our
rook and you know what yes brilliant
young man what did you think right okay
so let's just look at this situation for
a moment White has advanced his King
early in the opening so has black by the
way blacks King is no great shakes over
there young man
yes well g2 will take the knight so
black if he wants can capture the pawn
but one of the things I've been
lecturing about time and time and time
again here at the club and I really like
to emphasize this is chess as a team
game you got to involve everybody on
your team and and the comments are
correct this knight on f6 could jump to
g4 that's very good this knight on f6
could jump to e4 capturing upon also
very good but-but-but-but and we should
think about this wouldn't it be
brilliant if this Bishop on CHS is a
team game we got to involve everybody
you don't this Bishop isn't earning its
job it's not earning its pay it's
getting paid and it's not moving young
man yes this night on d7 should get out
of the way so our Bishop can go to g4 so
one idea for black and maybe not the
only idea is that he could play the move
Knight b6 as the young gentleman
suggested are we sure we'll think about
this in a moment
the knight attacks the knight but also
the bishop is threatening to come here
with check to the king which will cost
white his queen woo so but this this
type of a threat is called a double
attack because black has two attacks
attack number one and attack number two
Donna can fill adored didn't say that
Knight b6 was the best move this man who
is 300 years old he said the best move
for black was Knight C Phi whoa that's
pretty wild
remember a moment ago in this position
there was two suggestions suggestion
number one was to take this pawn with
the night and suggestion number two was
to move this Knight to g4 to attack this
pawn on f2 now if we look at the move
Knight c5 woo this Knight wants to take
this pawn this Bishop wants to go to g4
woo what could white do okay he can take
the knight and now comes this
devastating check
wait what what if he moves the bishop we
can't block the check that's not allowed
that would put our King in immediate
capture whoo so this is what Philidor
said so hold on is that all that
Philidor said no he said that the move
king e too can be defeated by the move
Knight c5 instead he recommended for
white that white play the move rook f1
this way this way the rook is protected
by the king correct
Charlie you have a comment okay
Queen takes h2 so Charlie has a very
good idea he he likes grabbing pawns and
they're my favorite snack food as well I
love grabbing pawns but remember chess
is a team game and right now the only
guy on blacks team it's an all-star we
admit is this Queen on g2 that Queen on
g2 is doing a great job but look at the
rest of blacks guys this guy's okay this
guy's okay this guy's okay but they're
not really working they're not really
working this rook is really not working
at all and neither is this bishop so
Philidor had an idea yeah this 300
year-old got he said my goodness
wouldn't it be wonderful if black bishop
could move all the way here if blacks
bishop could move to h3 the Queen could
capture the rook with Czech winning on
an entire rook but the bishop it's
illegal according to our rules of chess
the knight is blocking the pathway of
the bishop exactly
that was what Philidor thought we got to
move our knight but if we move our
knight here and attack the knight well
he may just trade he thought that what
he needed to do was give this knight a
good square so you know what he came up
with he traded this pawn let's take a
look what see what happens so now you
guys are our matching width with a man
who's 300 years old
what would you do with white young man
yes exactly he took your pawn white
wants to recapture this pawn Queen takes
d4 okay now Philidor said I've created a
good Square for my knight this pawn
trade opened up the e5 square and
Philidor played Knight e5 now can
somebody tell me what this Knight is
threatening to do young man
right if the Queen took the night the
pond would happily take the Queen and
that would be terrible young man what do
you think attacking the knight that
would be a good move but what is black
threatening to do charlie precisely
brilliant
the knight is threatening to come to f3
check which would attack the correct
that's what it's called a fork hold on
so this Knight is threatening
devastation with Knight f3 check is
there a second threat besides moving the
knight here remember what Philidor wrote
about this bishop young man in the back
yes that's a second threat right oh but
what happened
shall we go back just a few moves here a
moment ago remember this position and
remember how excited we were about
sacrificing our bishop oops
remember how excited we were about
sacrificing the bishop and we got a kick
of hips and we got a position like this
awesome I did it wrong again
King g8 and we got to this position we
were so excited we were forking the
Queen in the rook right and we were
thinking that white was in great shape
but then Philidor told us oops Philidor
told us that surprise surprise after
this move Knight e5 we're threatening
here the best move was the move that
that young man said f4 attacking the
knight black
attacks our rook whoo yeah now what you
do true the let's take a look let's take
a look okay just a moment let's see
what's wrong with this move we all agree
white just killed upon right that was
pretty good
no because you can't you you lost you
won upon but maybe you lost a rook so
let's say black captures the rook
White's King can go here but now black
has a checkmate in one turn in one move
Charlie do you see it Knight see four
check and mate isn't that cute let's see
if we can understand why it's checkmate
first of all the knight is in fact
attacking the King so it is check the
King can't move to any of these squares
all of these squares are protected the
Queen protects this square this square
and this square the knight protects that
square and the Queen protects d3 so it's
checkmate let's go that's true that and
the King's pieces are in the way of his
King okay let's imagine that white moves
his rook okay now now what on earth can
black do black is winning but I need you
guys to show me why what's the move
Queen GT okay we can take that but look
at what my computer did the moment we
took that pawn with our queen the
computer pointed out the knight protects
the pawn
the white knight protects the pawn so
capturing that pawn with the Queen isn't
so good charlie
queen g1 check that indeed is the best
move okay so now I'm pretty clever I
realize that I can't move the rook back
here if I was to move the rook back to
f1 what would you guys do young man
take the cream absolutely right so I
think the computer does so I'm going to
play the move King - D - yeah yeah King
D - and I think that white is winning is
that true no okay I need you to tell me
why because Philidor said that in this
position black was winning young man in
the blue all the way that yeah Knight c4
remember last move that and move Knight
c4 was devastating that was the
checkmate but in this case the knight
isn't protected he would take our Knight
and worse
that's right the worst part is that when
we take this nitrogen when we take this
night we don't have time to grab the
rook because the Queen's checking our
King who was the idiot that put the King
on g8 I mean if that King wasn't there
it would be an excellent move now now
now now now now you guys you guys got to
find the devastating move for black
Charlie Bishop f1 now that's clever
bishop f1 I like that move because
Charlie you know that with a bishop on
f1 you're protecting the square c4 so
Bishop f1 is good but you remember what
what world champion Michael tall said
you remember what Michael tall said if
you see a good move wait
don't play it right away think maybe you
have a better move young man in the
white yes what do you think knight c6 is
it a nice move keep in mind that this
pawn is in fact attacking our knight and
I find that very scary
I don't want white to capture my knight
I like my Knights so I don't want to
lose the knight
so the move knight c6 attacking White's
Queen is very compelling but it's a
retreating move maybe there's something
better young man in the green yes yeah
ooh
isn't that a brilliant move
isn't that a brilliant move this is what
Philidor wrote 300 years ago
Philidor wrote about this position he
said something like when Jew and the
game Judah Newman it's hard to translate
the French it's a whites whites game is
lost
adieu Newman who I'll think about it in
a moment
the knight attacks the King it attacks
the Queen do you see that white could
capture the knight
yes young men that's precisely right and
making a check and Philidor wrote what
would you do after the rook blocks the
check young man hahahahaha
no fair see and what did the computer
say what will black do should we see
what the computer said well it didn't
show okay young man what would you do if
you were black precisely that's what the
computer said and if I retreat my king
what
the bishop to f5 now this would be
Bishop f5 correct Bishop g4 Knight to
Knight e 2 and now this checkmate in one
move what is it charlie
good Wow okay
but right now White's King is facing a
devastating check look at that the King
cannot move to c1 the bishop occupy the
King can't move to d2 the King can't
move to e1 what move what else could
white do okay very good rook to f3 does
block the check and now young man okay
that's a very good move winning the rook
with check but is there something better
young man in the back yes Bishop takes
f3 check and now right now the knight
has to come here and Charlie is your
checkmate still good yes what's the
other checkmate
ah hahaha so there's only one checkmate
and Charlie got it right but this is a
checkmate the Queen attacks the king and
it is protected the Queen's protected by
that Bishop on f3 so let's go back a
second because remember when I was
starting the lecture from the very very
very starting position and I said that
this square is vulnerable and that many
times white players try to target this
square so they can give an early
devastating checkmate but just because
we're on the attack doesn't mean that
the attack always wins
in fact sometimes the defense wins as
well so just because you think you're
winning oops
doesn't mean that it's a hundred percent
exactly so it turns out that this
sacrifice which looks really devastating
for white you have to look deeply into
position just like Philidor did 300
years ago what yes
so this is this is how that that that
line of play developed that we just saw
Black had to avoid moving as king here
he had to avoid moving his King here he
went back with his king we followed up
with this devastating for we thought it
was devastating but it turned out that
it was the counter-attack this move
Queen take G to that Andre denikin
Philidor had analyzed 300 years ago and
he was correct young man
that night that went all the way over
here and what a rook didn't play it it
didn't play a role in the game
afterwards
yes well here in this position
essentially white didn't get an
opportunity after this move Queen takes
g2 this rook was under attack let me
suggest another line of defense let's
see if you guys could beat me if after
this move remember we recaptured this
pawn with our Queen and then the knight
came here and the bishop came here and
suddenly White was under a great attack
let me suggest how would you guys defeat
me if I move my knight here what would
you do what would you do would you give
up just checking just asking so first of
all you could take the pawn but that
wouldn't invoke you didn't like that
pawn capture either I agree
I remember chess is a team game you got
to get these guys into play young man
Knight e5 excellent move the same idea
as we saw a moment ago in this moment
you guys have me scared you're
threatening to play Knight here and what
would that be charlie
smother checkmate with the night so that
is why I prepared this move Knight
captures d4 so I'm protecting this
square f3 with my knight now now how are
you guys going to be Charlie you're
you're ready to go okay let's take a
look at that one
I love capturing pawns with check I
better block with my bishop hmm
not so easy to kill me huh huh huh
young man in the back do you like Queen
takes e4 no what would you have done
instead very good Bishop h3 bringing
everybody into the attack now I don't
want to lose my rook right so I play
Queen here to defend my rook I'm
protecting my rook that was a good idea
of me that was a good idea don't you
think now I don't hear everybody jumping
up and down with joy
so less mean I did something good I
slowed you guys down Charlie what do you
what
okay night fg4 okay I don't know but now
I'm very excited maybe I can go here
know if check if you guys move your king
if you move your king I'll go here check
that's pretty good let Charlie yes
correct
that was my question well I didn't hear
to take the Queen oh man you guys are
too sharp oh boy oh boy I've got to
figure out something I'll tell you what
I'll move my bishop instead to e3 now
what will you guys do I could then the
pawn will correct
don't take the bishop but what was the
idea behind this move charlie
right so your idea was to free the dark
squared bishop and to attack which pawn
and to attack the F pawn besides the F
pawn what other pond is this Knight
attack young man in the back hey hutch I
was trying to cover correct you wanted
to take the pawn on h2 so now if I
Castle now Charlie Bishop g4 is an
excellent move you attack the queen but
after Bishop g4 I'll block with f3 what
else could you do young man in the back
yeah correct you just take a whole rook
duck and let's say finally finally
finally in this position I'm going to
move my I don't know I'm going to attack
I'm going to play f4
I don't know I played f4 what do you
guys do
do you guys resign I was hoping young
man Knight this Knight to f3 I can take
it yes young man what do you think I was
hoping for that move because if that was
my trick when I push my pawn to f4 I was
hoping that you wouldn't realize that I
had unmasked an attack against your
queen so that when you move your Bishop
to g4 I would pick your Greek that was
my hope young man what would you do
instead yes that was an eye hos hope and
you wouldn't see that devastating move
and now I'm going to take your knight
I'm going to take your knight be afraid
Charlie that move is too good after
Knight takes III let's check the
situation 1 2 3 4 1 2 White's missing
two bishops correct we could say black
is winning so will Paul it will we'll
end the lecture here and just say that
just because you're attacking and
sacrificing your pieces doesn't
guarantee you victory sometimes good
defense followed by a counter-attack can
win as well
you